hello Finland its Colonel Brian your
golden god I am just a projection on a
screen but even I can say my god it's
cold out here still your loyalty keeps
me warm
so arise my people arises one and demand
that my show appear in my beloved
Finland until that day comes I will make
you this solemn promise starting today
I'm going on a hunger strike a hunger
strike that only includes Finnish foods
I will continue to eat a lot of Chinese
food French food Mexican food Italian
Korean barbecue Orleans gumbo I will
have lots of steaks potatoes everything
out candy bars I'll stuff my fat face
but no Finnish food until I'm on the air
in your country this includes no sealy
no VC poor oh no truthfully yet and as I
grow weaker and weaker from lack of
Mustafa Cara
you must get stronger never give up
never give up until I'm on in your
country thank you for your loyalty
Finland also thank you for inventing
Angry Birds
it's crazy yeah it's just they got big
fat bird that explodes I wanted to leave
you by playing the Finnish national
anthem that's how I wanted to end this
speech but we don't know what that is
and we couldn't even find it on
Wikipedia so instead please enjoy it no
cost to us the public domain song
camptown races
[Applause]
[Music]